okay so I'm here outside this house and
this is a really interesting house
because it's in Bournville and if this
was actually one of the no it wasn't one
of the it was the very first house that
I ever actually bought ten years ago now
or just over ten years ago and it's also
the most recent property that I've ever
bought and the reason is is because ten
years ago I bought that property but I
couldn't put it in my name because ten
years ago I was only seventeen so I
wasn't even 18 so the property what
happened was I actually put it in a
family member's name and I've been
meaning to switch it over to mine now
and perhaps through the ages but it's
not as easy as just switching it over
you see when we bought that property
I've actually done a video explaining
how I bought that property age 17 with
no money so if you want to check out how
about I probably just click the link
just above my head but it's been sitting
in someone else's name but in trust for
me for 10 years and the mortgage on it
was a hundred thousand pounds that's the
mortgage outstanding on the property now
the really cool thing is the mortgage is
a hundred thousand pounds I bought it
effectively for a hundred thousand
pounds but now the property is worth
about 185 185 so it's gone up in value
it's almost doubled in value over the
last 10 years despite there being a
recession and everything it's almost
doubled in vs. now with 185 so when
we've transferred it over if I I've just
bought it off my family member for a
hundred thousand pounds paid off the
mortgage and I've bought it for cash and
I'm now giving it a refurb because it's
not hardly had any work on it at all for
the last ten years so I'm giving it a
refurb and then I'm gonna refinance it
and not only will it be it wasn't no
money down deal now when I buy it for a
hundred and refinance it at 185 I'll be
able to pull out so much cash so much
equity from the property so it's
fantastic so it's been a right little
gem it's gonna make me a lot of money
now when I refinance it once the work is
finished but even better than that I've
been making a thousand pound a month
profit just shy maybe 900 no
100 pound a month after all cost profit
on that house for the last 10 years so
it's just incredible so I'll show you
around the house now and show you what's
going on this is the house okay so this
is the lounge which is currently being
renovated and painted as we speak it's
very messy but that's because we've just
moved all the tenants out to do the
property yeah so this is the lounge and
this is used as a communal area got the
kitchen through here without wonderful
decorator hey man what's up bro he's
doing a fantastic job
property is really looking good bathroom
but some of this water in painted
kitchens being changed for being changed
doing up all the work so downstairs
there is a sitting room it was a sitting
room but we turned it into a bedroom by
putting a bed in it so this room for the
last 10 years so it's just insane our
longest-standing temp has been in this
room it was a guy called Mitch Ashe and
he lived in this room for six years and
he just paid a rent of 365 pounds lived
in this room really happy so we've only
had four tenants ever in this room and
who would have known because when I
bought it it was told to me that this
was a sitting room so a scholar
fantastic I'll take you upstairs as well
so we've got one bedroom downstairs and
we've got three bedrooms upstairs and
they've all been rented out it's pretty
much been a hundred percent occupied
since I bought it ten years ago so
because we're doing a lot of work we've
actually moved two tenants out apart
from 110 so this room is still occupied
so we won't go in there but these two
fact that room is actually the biggest
they've got quite a large double room in
there this is a single room it's 80
square feet
and this room is also a single room
that's 72 square feet it looks kind of
tiny on the video small and despite them
sharing a bathroom sharing your kitchen
it's in Bournville I bought it for a
hundred thousand pounds I've been
getting the rent on average of one
thousand five hundred and fifty pounds a
month by renting out the rooms and I
didn't put a penny down and now not only
did I not put a penny down but I'll be
refinancing it back up to its true value
which is now a hundred and eighty-five
thousand pounds can you believe it so
it's not an officially lease option
agreement because but it's a little bit
similar at least option agreement is
where you buy a property now pay for it
later
this property although that wasn't a
lease option agreement it was more a
family member was hauling it forward
it's a very very similar principle so
really happy with this one
and let's go to the next house shower
excellent fantastic boom right next
property okay so we've just got the
second property it is one of these I
think it's that one there the white door
it is and I agreed to buy this property
for ninety eight thousand pounds in 2019
and today it's worth a hundred and
sixty-five thousand pounds can you
believe it I agreed to buy for ninety
eight thousand it's now worth one
hundred and sixty five thousand I agreed
to buy it seven years ago it's been
renting out for the last seven years for
about eighteen months
mister let me take you around it's
incredible this one has got tenants
inside I haven't seen it in absolutely
year so I really hope that the condition
is good we're obviously going to do some
work on it but hopefully so the lounge
you know what the tenants are keeping
the place clean and just give a little
left the kitchen is using a free nice
really good bathroom again
good I mean the main thing that we're
going to need to do is just paint paint
we're thinking of new carpets let me
look at the carpets on the stairs see
what you think
the carpets there okay but if we did
change them it would just the carpets
always give the house a real lift and it
means that I mean look on the stairs
there
okay but lovely tenancy a great people a
lot of the terms have been it for
absolute yes so I won't go in all the
rooms because they're all talented but
as you can see we've got little ki sex
outside each room so if a tenant gets
locked out it's all systemized this ten
years so and the room downstairs which
is where Georgie lives downstairs hoops
even the lights go off automatically so
the tenants can't leave the lights on
how come back nearly four years all
right fantastic right tenants great
house see how can you say that it's not
passive income when you've got five
tenants in a house really happy pay
their rent on time that paying 1750 no
eighteen eighteen hundred they're paying
in rent
so it's up at 1,800 M from rent and they
are all really happening they'll get on
it up in there for years and if there
are any issues they contact the HMO
management company that look after it
that take ten percent and then if the
HMO management company needs looking
after all needs managing
then we have our staff who are overseer
who contacts thing I don't get involved
in this it's not that the chat you can
see how happy the tenants are you do not
have to be super involved to keep the
tenant super happy you just need
somebody to be so it's fantastic so that
has one of the figures lease option
agreement that house I bought it for
ninety eight grand it's got five tenants
in paying eighteen hundred pound a month
I bought it for ninety eight grams rents
have gone up house prices have gone up
it's now worth one hundred and sixty
five thousand pounds and that's just the
bricks and mortar valuation so
absolutely stoked you know what there's
loads more houses around here I could
show you two but I think twos enough for
today we've got apartments HMOs family
homes these terminal refinements them
pull my money
our lease option agreement you know with
property you got to be patient sometimes
you need to just wait for the prices to
rise but the cash flow has been very
very good as well fix the boxes so burn
that's it now that there are a couple
houses that's the power of lease option
agreement people say they're too good to
be true or won't have all that at work
listen not only do they work for
cashflow they've been working for me for
cash flow for the last seven years but
now I'm buying like almost 50% below
market value because I set the price
ages and ages ago so the key is what's
the lesson from this the key is you need
to go and find properties now you need
to offer the full market value but
agreed to buy them or pay for them in
five six seven years time in the
meantime benefit from the rents and then
benefit from the capital appreciation
but what I'm going to do at the end of
the at the end of the agreement you're
gonna buy them for like forty fifty
percent below market value and if you
can't buy them because you have got the
money find the frickin money you think I
would sell coke for the money I haven't
got the 98 grand to buy this house I
know it's worth 180 or whatever it's
worth but I haven't got the 98 grand no
I'll find the ninety eight grand
and then all we finance that and I'll
pull all of my money out and more and if
for whatever reason it hasn't gone up in
value then I'll just walk away because
it's the lease option agreement not the
obligation agreement it's property easy
I think so I think so if you know what
you're doing if you know what you're
doing it's really straightforward has it
taken time to put the systems in place
etc etc turn this into true passive
income absolutely but it's so worth it
it's so worth it because now I can get
my rent comes in no matter what I'm
doing I've just had a baby boy I'm at
home I'm on the beach wherever I am I
get paid from these houses because you
can see the systems are so good so you
need to buy the right properties at the
right time in the right area with the
right systems if you want to learn about
how to do that more why not come and
join me at the property investors crash
course because it's too far away because
I'm not free on those dates if you can
take yourself out the game the very
first hurdle the very first hurdle and
you can't get to the crash course you'll
never be successful anyway so get your
ass to the crash course and let me show
you exactly how to do this stuff so you
can buy houses like this - boom shocka
see you next time thanks so much for
watching
there were so many people that told me
not to buy these houses they said you
know all those about to be a big
recession guess what I made so much
money off these two houses through the
recession guess what those people are
doing the people that said don't buy
those two houses ten years later I'm a
multimillionaire they are doing the
exact same thing in the same job just
take action